I'm ascending everyday for example the
British newspapers everyday offend me
with their laziness their nastiness and
their inaccuracy
but I'm not going to expect someone to
stop that happening I should just simply
speak out about it you know sometimes
when people are offended they want to
some it is just come in and say right
stop that to whoever is offending them
and of course as a former chairman the
BBC once said there are some people one
would wish to offend and I think there's
truth in that too so the idea that you
have to be protected from any kind of
uncomfortable emotion is one I
absolutely do not describe subscribe to
in a fellow that I helped write two
books about psychology and psychiatry
was a renowned psychiatrist in London
called Robin Skinner said something very
interesting we said if people can't
control their own emotions then they
have to start trying to control other
people's behavior and when you're around
super-sensitive people you cannot relax
be spontaneous because you no idea
what's going to upset them next and
that's why I've been warned
recently don't go to most university
campuses because the political
correctness has been taken from being a
good idea which is let's not be mean
particularly to people who are not able
to look after themselves very well
that's a good idea to the point where
any kind of criticism or any individual
or group can be labeled cruel and the
whole point about humor the whole point
about comedy and believe you me I've
thought about it is that all comedy is
critical even if you make a very
inclusive joke like how do you make God
laugh answer telling your plans now
that's about the human condition it's
not excluding anyone it's saying we all
have all these plans which probably
won't come and isn't it funny how we
still believe they're going to have
so that's a very inclusive jury still
critical or humor is critical if you
start saying oh we mustn't be muscled
criticized or offend them and humors
gone with humor gives a sense of
proportion and then as far as I'm
concerned you're living in 1984